what is it like being single
i
like it i like
starting each day with a sense of
possibility
and i'm optimistic
because every day i get a little more
desperate
and desperate situations yield the
quickest results yes
it is true i michael scott am signing up
with an online dating service thousands
of people have done it and i am going to
do it i need a username
and i have a great one
little kid lover that way people will
know exactly where my priorities are at
oh wow look at those how nice for you
up there front and center beautiful i
think they would look better right here
they're very pretty and i wouldn't want
them to fall
i was a little nervous when pam told me
he was her boss but he doesn't act like
a boss at all
if i had a boss like that we'd never get
anything done
so what do you think about what
about julie
you're seeing nice yeah yeah do you like
her uh yeah sure
so pam was right well what about you two
hitting up
[Music]
well
apparently
michael scott
is on a date
and that
that's my friend
changes everything
no question about it i am ready to get
hurt again
okay
wendy
hot and juicy redhead
let's give this a try
wendy's
hello
wendy this is kevin's friend michael
this isn't wendy oh i'm sorry could you
put her on please dude this is a wendy's
restaurant
damn it kevin okay um
could i just have a frosty and a baked
potato please you have to come to the
restaurant to order food well send
somebody to pick it up just have it
ready and it's ready now
well i'll put it aside
hello hi i can't talk right now i'm
sorry oh okay whoo i'm really nervous
yeah we do yeah
when i get nervous i sort of clam up oh
well that's fine oh it's better for me
just to be quiet yeah yeah
hi can i point something out to you sure
you're actually talking a lot yeah sorry
it's the other thing i do when i get
really nervous
okay here we go here we go oh god
just relax yep i'm good
wow
i feel like a human juice box
uh hawaiian blood punch oh that's chris
type ocean spray
stop it stop it
yeah
what i looked at the bag i looked
straight at the bag
that's not good could you distract me
for a second just talk about things that
don't have blood in them
well
okay um
bags
what
that was me um a hat
a hat a hat with no blood in it
that is full of soup
you're cute
what you're done
oh already oh we did it oh wow i was so
nervous about this i don't think i ate
for three days
we should have your contract done by
thursday oh great
great i will look out for that step then
okay and um you know i just wanted to
say it was really
really nice to do business with you yeah
it was nice to do business with you
thank you
did i
get everything
yeah i think so
okay
so oh donna yeah do you need validation
we don't we don't validate no it's just
in the lot thank you so much you're
welcome you're
welcome
bye
so um so if
there's any other questions that you
have i don't have uh
any other questions
i'm just gonna
make my way
down
all right
bye bye
have a good elevator ride
oh what's that out there
michael how did it go
bros before hoes why because your bros
are always there for you they've got
your back
after your hoe rips your heart out for
no good reason
and you were nothing but great to your
home
and you told her that she was the only
hoe for you and that she is better than
all the other hoes in the world
and then
then suddenly she's not your hoe no moe
pam you're trustworthy thank you and a
woman oh no and i want you to listen to
a voicemail from my boss
michael it's jim i guess i missed you
i'll uh be there this afternoon for
performance reviews
i hope it's understood that that will be
our only topic of discussion
see you soon first impressions
uh just off the top
i think she'll be here this afternoon
my boss is coming in today the lovely
jan levinson gould will well no gould
the gold has been
divorced
um
the awkward part is that this is the
first time we'll be seeing each other
since
well
uh it was really nothing we just sort of
got caught up in the moment
the vulnerable divorcee
gives herself to the understanding with
rugged good looks office manager
just uh
she didn't want it to continue for some
reason
it we both didn't i didn't want we both
didn't want it to continue
was not professional
um
when people say something's mutual it
never is
but this was mutual
thank you very much
our suspect has straight brown hair
she is wearing blue jeans and a black
top
so behold our bachelorette
give her a 10 for looks and a three for
her ability to describe herself
hello my lady
michael
uh
are you michael scott
so michael what
oh
i'm sorry i'm i'm supposed to be meeting
someone named michael oh that's not
michael
large hot chocolate with caramel and a
shot of peppermint
oh boy
hey michael where you been
hey you're supposed to hit the white
ball first buddy
nice one can i talk to you for a second
mm-hmm all right
everything okay why are you wearing a
hat now guys come on i'm on a date let
me do my thing
hi i'm date mike nice to meet me
how do you like your eggs in the morning
hey guys guys guys use everyone watch
this ready
what are you doing i'm trying to knock
your stump with my top michael you'd
have to do this
wow
oh well i was close
i would say i kind of have an unfair
advantage because i watch reality dating
shows like hawk and i learn i absorb
information from the strategies of the
winners and the losers actually i
probably learn more from the losers
these people need love and i am going to
get it for them
who cares if we sell a little bit less
paper today a great boss cares more
about the happiness of his employees
than anything else
i'm going to be cupid and i'm going to
shoot my sparrow an unsuspecting victims
and they are going to get hit
and say
i'm in love i was hit by cupid sparrow
funny little bird but he gets the job
done
you